well if you're feeling a bit narky this
Monday morning this is gonna put a smile
on your face almost 8000 meters below
the surface of the Pacific Ocean
somewhere off the coast of Peru a new
type of smiling fish has been discovered
it's officially called a snail fish and
scientists say that unlike most deep-sea
creatures it hasn't got those gnashing
teeth or those creepy goggly eyes is
actually quite an attractive fish and
science correspondent Thomas More as
we're taking a closer look the Pacific
Ocean off the coast of Peru and this
camera equipment is on a four-hour
freefall to the deep almost 8,000 meters
down it hits the bottom of the Atacama
Trench and reveals life that's never
been seen before a new species of snail
fish they're no more than 30 centimetres
long with barely a bone in their
translucent bodies the immense pressure
of the water holds the gelatinous flesh
together they go against the mold of
what you'd imagine for a deep-sea fish
you know there's no gnashing teeth
there's no creepy bulbous eyes and
they're sort of small pink jelly like
fish they look as if they're smiling
they've got quite a playful wave that
they swim around so I found quite
endearing and I think it's useful to see
you know the world's deepest fish is is
quite an attractive animal it's quite
it's quite a beautiful animal the team
from Newcastle University found three
new species of snail fish a family named
after a shallow-water cousin that bears
a closer resemblance to the mollusk
despite the perpetual darkness and
temperatures just above freezing it's
not a bad place to live
this deep there beyond the reach of
predators and there are plenty of small
creatures living on the seabed for them
to feed on ever more robust equipment is
allowing scientists to take cameras to
parts of the ocean they couldn't reach
before and it's a secret world that's
full of surprises Thomas More Sky News